The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good evening, people.
I want to continue
our discussion
of the end of the studio era,
the advent of the kind of much
freer, more independent, more
politically and even morally
liberated movies that
appear after the Hollywood
dispensation has subsided.
But remember that I've
also been suggesting to you
that even though there's
a certain sense in which
a kind of artistic
freedom was now granted
to directors and
to American films,
and on balance I think most
scholars and film buffs
looking at the 1970s
would certainly
share my sense that it's
a very remarkable decade.
But I think they might
also share my sense
that the films had given
up more than they realized,
certainly more than
they were conscious of,
that the shift in what
we might call the media
ecology of the society, which
enabled this level of freedom
for movies, also carried
with it a tremendous cost.
And remember how
decisive the numbers are.
I've mentioned them a
few times in this course.
At the height of the studio
era, 2/3 of the country
is going to the
movies every week.
It's an habitual experience
for most Americans,
both adults and
children, really.
By the time this
system comes to an end,
by the time the
movies have been,
as I've suggested several
times in the course,
supplanted by television as
the new central storytelling
system of the society,
by the time that
occurs at the end of
the '60s, most Americans
are going to the movies
only once a year.
And it's only particular
subcultures-- teenagers,
for example, who make a regular
habit of going to the movies.
And a good deal of the
triviality and superficiality
of movies of many
of the box office
successes of the '80s and '90s
from the American film industry
is a direct function of
the fact that the audience
had dwindled from
the whole society
to particular subsets
of the society.
And the consequences
for the nature
of-- the movie's sense of
its connection to the society
are powerful, are profound.
Well, we're going
to explore aspects,
finally-- our final exploration
of aspects of this topic
comes in tonight's
lecture, and especially
in the exemplary
early 1970s film
McCabe and Mrs.
Miller that we're
going to screen for
you after my lecture.
I want to begin by
talking a little bit
about Robert Altman's career.
And I'll actually look
at certain specific films
and say a few things
about them in a minute.
But first let me
talk about what I
take to be some of his--
not only the only ones,
but some of his defining
qualities as a director--
signature features of his work.
The first and most
obvious to me is
what we might call
his moral skepticism.
He really is in some respects
temperamentally an outsider.
And it's interesting
to speculate,
I think, about what
might have happened
to Robert Altman, an immensely
gifted natural filmmaker,
had he been born a
generation earlier
and had to actually struggle
with the requirements
and responsibilities, the
confinements of the studio
system.
But luckily for
Altman, he emerges
in the time when the
tyranny of the studios
and also the creative input of
the studios has disappeared,
has gone away.
And in that sense, he
represents a new kind
of independent
spirit in filmmaking.
And he resembles some of
the other directors who
come of age at roughly the same
time, directors some of whom
I mentioned this afternoon,
like Scorsese or Coppola or Alan
Pakula.
So one of his defining
qualities is a kind
of moral skepticism, a kind
of sympathy, we might call it,
which is connected
to what we might call
his sympathy for the marginal.
Over and over again
in Altman's films,
we focus on either
marginal figures who
are reluctantly or inadequately
part of a larger community,
or we focus on a community
that itself is so dubious
as a community, so
damaged as a community, so
enfeebled and unlike the
traditional communities
that it's as if the
community he treats itself,
the societies or groupings
that he finds interesting,
are also in some deep way
non-traditional communities.
And in fact, in McCabe
and Mrs. Miller,
most of the supporting cast were
literally members of a commune.
They were members of
the counterculture.
The ballad that is sung
by the great balladeer,
American singer Leonard Cohen
in the beginning of the film,
would have struck
knowledgeable viewers
as a deeply subversive gesture.
Because think how often the
Western begins with a ballad,
with someone saying a ballad,
as if the stories of the West
have become so
mythological that they're
part of our song tradition,
our musical tradition-- which
is true-- as well as
our narrative tradition.
And many, many
classic Westerns begin
with a ballad of some kind.
The Searchers has such a ballad,
in fact, as I hope you noticed.
Well, McCabe and Mrs.
Miller begins with a ballad,
as you'll see.
But it's a subversive ballad.
It's sung by a
man, Leonard Cohen,
who's deeply associated
with marijuana,
with the counterculture, with
striking out against authority,
with writing anti-war songs.
And there's a kind of
countercultural ambience,
a kind of countercultural
skepticism
and sympathy for the
margins in nearly all
of Robert Altman's work.
So his moral
skepticism then could
be said to have at
least two dimensions.
One is what we might call an
aesthetic dimension, in which
he is skeptical about the
inherited strategies, belief
systems, and even structures
of earlier movies.
And he actually is in that
sense aesthetically subversive,
although very
subtly so, as I hope
you'll see in tonight's film.
He'll very often give you a
film that seems on the surface
to sustain and to recreate
all the classic conventions
of the genre in
which he's working.
And it's only when you
look a little bit more
closely that you realize
that although the structural
elements are there, they have
been perverted or inverted
so that they have in
some sense enacted
some kind of moral
migration and stand
for virtually alternative
beliefs, assumptions, or values
from what they
normally are taken
to stand for in the classic
genre films on which Altman is
borrowing, or against which he
is engaged in a kind of mockery
or at least hostile
action of some kind.
And I think that McCabe and
Mrs. Miller demonstrates
this very dramatically,
although most of Altman's films
have these qualities
in some degree.
The second quality of
his moral skepticism
is what would be not now related
to his aesthetic principles,
to his filmmaking
practice, but would
be more broadly
associated with politics,
with his general ideological
view of the world.
And even there,
especially there maybe,
Altman styled himself a rebel.
Even when he was successful in
Hollywood in his early career
when he was so-- MASH
was a box office success.
And the decade of
1970 through '80
is probably the richest
decade of Altman's career.
And in that time, even though
Altman was very successful,
later he fell into disfavor
with the Hollywood bosses
and he spent some period of his
career underground in a way,
either not making movies
at all-- directing plays
in various places or
making documentary films
or private films that were
not released commercially.
Then he has a resurgence later,
before the end of his life.
The last 10 or 15
years of his life
again involve successes
at the box office.
So the second aspect
of his moral skepticism
might be a kind of
political skepticism,
and a political skepticism both
against the Hollywood system
and then against the
larger political structures
of the society.
Now remember, his
political subversiveness
comes at a time when many
honorable and normal people,
including your professor,
were subversive in some sense,
because it was a time when the
country was at war in a war
that many people in
the country thought
was unreasonable and wrong.
Many people went to jail
or protested the war.
And Altman was on the side
of the anti-war forces.
He was on the morally
skeptical side
about wars of choice in
foreign environments.
So he was both
politically and culturally
a skeptic and
aesthetically a skeptic.
And both qualities show up
in his films in all kinds
of remarkable ways.
I've talked about how that
leads to a kind of sympathy
for marginality, for the
condition of marginality
and for characters who belong on
the margins of the society, who
live on the margins.
And he loved to make films
often about certain kinds
of human communities, subsets,
small versions of human society
comprised entirely of misfits
and marginal characters.
And he even has a
sympathy for what
we might think of as
unconventional appearance,
so that many of the
actors and especially
the secondary background
actors in his films
might actually be in
ads for grotesquerie.
He loves the grotesque.
And at least his
background characters
often have a sort of
grotesque element.
There's a love of the weird
and the strange in Altman
that you can feel in his
films, in his casting
and in his subject matter.
Another thing that
I would identify
as a kind of defining
quality for Robert Altman
is the relation in his films,
especially his mature films,
between plot and character.
There's a tendency-- it's
an aspect of his skepticism.
He doesn't like structures
that control him.
And from one angle, if you
think about storytelling
or narrative, plot is a
kind of controlling feature,
especially if you
allow the plot to take
the foreground of
the-- to assume
a position in the
foreground of the text,
the plot can become
a kind of iron hand,
controlling the choices the
director makes, controlling
what can happen
to the characters.
And certain forms of action
adventure-- what happens next,
the sequence of events
and the visual excitement
of watching those events, is
virtually the only interest
you have in film.
Those totally
plot-oriented films
tend to have stereotyped
or flat characters in them.
But Altman, even when he
embraces certain genre
principles that
require what looks
like a conventional
linear plot, often
tries to subvert the
linearity of his plot.
There's a kind of digressive or
dissenting, nonlinear tendency
in Altman's work.
You can sense it in
McCabe and Mrs. Miller,
although it doesn't emerge
totally fully until later
in his career, a little
bit later in his career.
The fullest embodiment of
this non-plot principle,
of this preference for
character over plot,
I think is probably the
film Nashville in 1975,
in which Altman displays an
immense range of characters
to us and skips
from one character
to another to another.
There are certain
centers of interest.
They seem to have no
connection to each other,
and you sit there in the film--
when the film first came out,
it actually elicited a
number of negative reviews
from reviewers who were
angry about the fact
that the film took virtually
its whole length to make clear
that in fact there
was a connection
between these characters.
The complaint against the
film was it was plotless.
Well, that wasn't exactly true.
It wasn't like plotless.
In fact, all the
lines of the plot
do come together toward
the end of the film.
But the truth is that
Altman is at least
as interested in digression as
he is in linear progression.
And there is a sense
in which his films
like to pause and savor
what's going on around them.
And as you're watching
McCabe and Mrs. Miller,
one of the things you might
ask yourself at a certain level
is what's the
throughline of the story?
In fact, it feels when you're
watching McCabe and Mrs. Miller
as if it doesn't have at least
a conventional Western plot.
As the film goes on,
you begin to realize,
yes, the story here is about
the growth of this town.
In that sense, the film
really is a founding myth,
an ironic, mocking,
founding myth.
But while you're
watching the film,
you're interested
in McCabe and you're
interested in some of the other
minor characters in the town.
But it's hard to identify what
the actual subject of the film
is, at first.
Altman likes to leave his
audiences in a little bit
of confusion of that sort.
He doesn't like to
satisfy the narrow desire
to have a clear, linear plot.
He prefers some
principles of digression.
And one of the reasons that
he does, apart from the fact
that he wants to savor the
experience of the world
and he's attentive to so
many aspects of experience
that he wants to often
bring all of them
into the film-- he's
very interested in sound,
for example, in the way
sound operates in the world.
And he does odd things
with his soundtrack,
as you'll see in
McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
I'll come back to
this in a minute.
His preoccupation,
then, is with trying
to create a situation in
which character unfolds.
And he'll always sacrifice what
a more action-oriented director
might think was the most
important thing in order
to explore character more fully.
Now, one very broad way
of dividing narratives,
as I may have suggested
earlier in the semester to you,
is a distinction
between plot-driven and
character-driven stories.
And one of the
things one can see
happening in Altman's
film-- again,
it's another marker of
the fact that Altman
is operating in a cinematic
environment that no longer has
the conservative aesthetic
constraints that are
placed upon a consensus system.
So can explore these kinds of
possibilities more fully than--
or can explore them
at all, in fact.
In some cases, he
couldn't have even looked
down these territories,
looked down
these pathways if he'd been a
conventional studio director.
So a distinctive feature,
then, of the way he works
is this tension between plot
and character and the emphasis
that Altman will almost
always put on character,
the way he'll even
subvert your interest
in what is going to happen
next some time in the film.
And as you're
watching McCabe you
might sort of think about that.
You don't ever feel that
the film is flagging.
You always are interested
in what happens.
But after a while,
you suddenly realize
that you're not
being carried along
by the momentum of story
itself in the way you
are in a normal film,
or what you would think
of as a conventional film.
And McCabe is only a
minor version of this.
As I say, Nashville is a much
more dramatic instance of this.
Finally, another distinctive--
not unique, but distinctive
feature of Altman's
work-- and this
occurs, especially powerfully
as his career continues.
You can sense it
earlier, but it actually
becomes a dominant topic
later in his career
after he's very successful.
He has great
confidence in himself.
By the last decade of his
life, he is conceived of,
I think, as a
master movie maker.
And he finds it very easy to get
people to appear in his films.
And that's where this
principle comes in most fully.
He's interested in blurring
the distinction between fiction
and reality.
And in fact, in
some of his films,
I think Nashville is the first
one in which this happens.
And then he returns to
this trick or this strategy
much later in his career
in a whole series of films.
In Nashville there
are some performers
who are playing themselves.
They're not
fictional characters.
Some of them are famous
singers and so forth.
And they appear as themselves.
Nashville is about the American
music scene, and also about
the turmoil of American
society in the 1970s.
And so many of the people
who appear in the film
are playing musicians, singers,
songwriters, and performers.
But there are actually
some real performers
who are recognized
by the audience
because they're relatively
famous, who play themselves.
This blurring of the
distinction of the difference
between fiction and
reality, this mingling
of fictional with
real characters
becomes a very
distinctive feature
of Altman's work
later in his career.
And very quickly then,
what I'd like to do
is show you a list
of some of his films.
You can put that up now, Greg.
I want to say something
about all of them.
This is not a full
list of his films.
And you can see, there's a long
interregnum of almost a decade
where he makes some films.
I just haven't
bothered to list them.
This is not a complete
listing of his films,
although I think it
is a complete listing
of his films made in the 1970s.
And I did that partly
because I wanted
you to see what a prolific
and productive decade
this was for Altman, but
also because I thought
you might be interested in
seeing how many titles register
with you.
Even if you're not
seen the films,
you've probably have heard
of some of these films,
because they are among the
most innovative and important
American films of the second
half of the 20th century.
I want to say a couple of things
about some of these films.
You've already seen the
ending of The Long Goodbye
and you know what a
deeply subversive version
of the detective
genre that film is.
I want to say a word
about California Split,
because in some ways it's a
film that most fully embodies
this principle of being
interested in the marginal.
California Split is
a gambler's movie.
And Eliot Gould, that sort
of shuckin' and jivin' figure
of anti-heroic
irony that you saw
at the end of The Long Goodbye
is the star of California Split
as well.
And almost the entire film--
a large part of the film
actually takes place
at the race track
and in gambling environments.
The climax of the film is
a trip to Las Vegas, where
our hero has a tremendous run
of luck, nearly breaks the bank.
And California Split follows the
fortunes of these two gamblers.
It's hard even fully to follow
the chronology of the film.
Sometimes you lose sense of
how much time has passed.
There are many things
about the characters
that are vague and unclear.
It's also a film--
parenthetically--
this is a trivial
detail, but it's always
struck me as a mark of Altman's
perversity-- every woman
in the film is named Barbara.
I especially notice this because
my wife is named Barbara.
I think the perversity had
to do with Altman's idea
that I'm creating a kind
of slice of life movie.
Thieves Like Us is a
particularly characteristic
Altman film, not
only because it has
a kind of plotless amorphousness
to it when you first
look at it, even though it
has great excitement in it
and a great emphasis
on character
and a great emphasis on
marginal, weird people
who sort of are not solid
citizens in any way.
But it also carries
another signature feature
of Altman's work, which I
did not list on my outline.
And that is, he was very
prone to allow his actors
to improvise when they
got in from the camera.
Or not literally
when he was shooting,
but they would improvise,
work something out.
He didn't work
from a set script,
or he would allow
departures from his script
very easily and quickly.
One of the reasons he loved
to work with Eliot Gould
was Eliot Gould was a
particularly gifted,
improvisational actor.
And there's a kind
of authenticity
in the performances in
most of Altman's films
that partly come
from the fact that he
was deeply interested
in trying to create
an illusion of authenticity that
was much more intense and much
more compelling than what
the traditional Hollywood
movie offers.
He really wasn't interested in
the fancy lighting and the very
elaborate patterning
of the Hollywood film.
He liked grit and
dirt and imperfection.
And you can feel these
elements in his work.
And you can especially
feel it often
in the performances
of his actors.
The ones who liked
working with him
really loved it,
because it gave them
a significant creative
part in the film itself.
So Thieves Like Us is a
relatively minor Altman film
in certain ways, but
it shows his interest
in character, his lack
of interest in plot,
and his love of the
marginal, and of course
of improvisational performance.
I've mentioned
Nashville already.
Maybe I should say
a little bit more
about it, simply
because it really
was an unbelievably
influential film.
The film seemed to
desert conventional plot,
and almost in an arbitrary
way for its first half, simply
to look at various characters
who had musical ambitions
and were bound for Nashville.
That was sort of the only
throughline in the film.
Everyone's going to Nashville.
And you really wondered as
you were watching the film,
what could these
characters possibly have
to do with each other?
Will they ever come together?
Should they come together?
It's a very artful film
in part because of the way
it plays with the
reader's frustration
about a linear plot.
And in fact, one of the
things the movie does
is it makes you aware as a
viewer of the extent to which
a linear plot is a kind of
crutch you lean on when you're
watching a movie.
It helps you sort of
get through the film.
If you're confused
about other stuff,
you always have that
throughline to grasp onto.
And when Altman takes
that away from you,
or seems to take
it away from you,
he immerses you in the
moral texture of his movie,
in the psychological
and political meanings
of his movies in a way
that would not be true
if you were fixated on what
happens next, what happens
next, what happens next.
I want to say a couple of words.
I've mentioned Buffalo Bill
and the Indians to you earlier.
And it's one of his most
subversive Westerns.
It's interesting that he went
back to the Western genre
in this very creative
period of his career.
And I think one
of the reasons was
he understood that there were
aspects of the genre he hadn't
made enough fun of.
He hadn't quite ruined
all the sacred truths,
to use a phrase that
I'm going to refer
to later that I
have on my outline
for McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
So he wanted to return again.
And that of course is the story
about those Wild West shows
I spoke about last week.
And the episode he
dramatizes actually
involves a comical and
also very disturbing
confrontation or interaction
between Great Chief Sitting
Bull and drunken Buffalo Bill,
and an absolutely corrupt,
drunken morally
muddled Indian hero,
played by incidentally
Paul Newman, who
had played upright
heroes frequently before.
And let me jump down a
little bit and say one word.
The films I've
listed from '88 on
are more recent films, all
of them relative successes.
My view is that his greatest
work is in the '70s.
But these later films I've
listed are interesting.
But I want to say a word
about Tanner and Tanner
on Tanner, because they show
how imaginative and experimental
he remained, even in his
later years as a director.
As some of you may know,
Tanner is not a movie.
It was a television series.
And it was a very
interesting television series
in which we could see Robert
Altman further developing
this interest he had in this
confusion between reality
and fiction.
I think he was right
about this in some ways.
Partly, I think, he
felt that because we
live in such a
media-saturated culture
and because of the power that
celebrity seems to exercise
in our culture, this
celebrity was often one
of Robert Altman's subplots.
It's a key subject in
Nashville and he returns to it
in a number of his
later films as well.
The trick of Tanner
is that it purports
to be a documentary following
a Democratic presidential
candidate in the Democratic
primaries of 1988.
And you've got an actor,
one of his favorite actors--
this actor-- I think his
name is Michael Murphy,
he has a role in
McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
He's the younger
company representative
who comes near the
end of the film
to negotiate with
McCabe about selling
his interest in the town.
And he's a wonderful actor,
this guy Michael Murphy.
And like many of the actors
who appear in Altman's films,
you have a sense, if
you watch Altman's films
over the whole of his
career, that there
was a repertory company that
kept coming back to work
with him again and again.
Eliot Gould must
be in six or seven
of his movies, Michael Murphy
in at least three or four.
He has favorite actresses too,
who love to work with him,
and Julie Christie is one,
the star of tonight's film.
Warren Beatty is another
of his favorite actors,
although Beatty was
such a big star that
could generate his own films.
He didn't need Altman as much as
some of these other actors did.
In any case, the
trick of Tanner,
the strategy of Tanner,
the really memorable thing
about Tanner was, I think, a
very significant television
event, is that the
fictional Tanner, played
by this guy Michael
Murphy, treated
with complete seriousness.
We mostly saw him through
the eyes of his press
managers, his press handlers.
So there was a great cynicism
about the political process
and the gossip of
journalists about
the presidential candidate.
But the real genius
of Tanner was
that we saw Tanner on the stump
with the real presidential
candidates.
And they cooperated.
The real presidential
candidates cooperated
in the making of the film.
And there are actually scenes in
which the fictional Tanner gets
into a conversation with
Michael Dukakis, who was also
running to be President.
And then there's an interview
with Michael Dukakis
in which Michael Dukakis
assesses the danger that Tanner
represents to his candidacy.
So when he returned to
Tanner on Tanner in 2004,
he elaborated this theory.
Now Tanner is a
retired politician,
and he's helping his daughter,
who's a documentary filmmaker,
do a new political film.
But now it's about
the contemporary.
It was about the last
election, the nomination.
I guess it was the first Bush
election was what it was about.
And it's very interesting.
He brings back many
of the characters.
Well, both of these texts,
like some of his other films,
are really preoccupied
with the question
of the blurred boundaries
between the fictional worlds we
live in and the actual
worlds we eat and breathe in,
and the extent to which our
media-saturated culture has
created a kind of
virtual reality
that we watch on television.
And now, of course, we watch
on our computer screens
that competes with the actual
reality we live every day.
Well, Altman loved playing
games with that question
and raising questions about it.
And the first Tanner series
is, among other things,
a powerful meditation
on the mendacity
and the stupidity of
the political process
in our country.
It showed people trying to raise
money, candidates scrambling
to get five minutes in
front of the news cameras
just at the moment when the
evening news is going to break,
that sort of thing.
It's very wonderfully
accurate, cynical account
of American politics.
Well, let me turn now to
McCabe and Mrs. Miller
and try to concretize
some of what
I've been saying with
specific reference
to this remarkable film.
"Ruin the sacred truths," a
line that I have plagiarized
from the Yale literary critic
and scholar Harold Bloom, who
uses it to describe
the enterprise
of certain romantic poets whose
aim was said, in Bloom's terms,
to ruin the inherited truths
of the society, to attack them,
to assault them.
And in a certain
sense, one could
say that that's
Altman's ambition
as well, to ruin, to
expose, to undermine,
to drench in irony the secret
truths that have come down
to us from cinematic
tradition, and maybe
from more political and
moral culture as well.
And we can see this in
many different aspects
of Altman's movie.
In many of his films
we feel these elements,
but especially powerfully
and especially clearly,
I think, in McCabe
and Mrs. Miller.
One might say, in fact, that the
whole energy of McCabe and Mrs.
Miller, the whole
energy of the film,
results in a kind
of tension or clash
between the conventional
expectations
that we have about
Westerns, and even
the conventional expectations
as they have been complicated
by the serious and
enlarging and already ironic
Westerns of the late
'50s and early '60s,
a kind of tension or clash
between the expectations
we have about traditional
Westerns, no matter how
ironic they might have been, and
the gritty, comical, uglified,
and humanized reality that
Altman actually presents us
with.
And almost every
element of the film
has this kind of shock
of recognition in it.
Let's take the question--
watch for example,
how the film treats
both the soundtrack
and what you visually see.
When the film first
came out, some reviewers
complained that they had
trouble making out the dialogue.
And they weren't
lying about this.
It's because when
Altman takes his camera
inside dingy saloon in
which some of the action
early in the film begins and to
which it returns periodically
as the film goes on,
Altman does not tamp down
the ambient noise in the bar.
You hear the conversation
of other people.
You hear bodies moving.
You hear various kinds of noise.
And sometimes, if
the people who are
in the foreground of the frame
are talking in very low voices,
their voices are blotted out
by the sounds around them.
And in fact, Altman's
treatment of sound
all the way through the film
has an energetic realism in it.
And it's a strange and
ultimately, I think,
very satisfying aspect of the
film, the way in which Altman
seems to try to create
a grittier, more
accurate account of the way
sound operates in our world.
The fact is, when
we're in actuality
and we address someone in a
crowded room, it's not quiet.
You can hear a lot
of other things.
Altman wants to sort
of recreate that.
And sometimes it almost
seems as if that tendency,
that digressive
tendency that I've said
is characteristic of
Altman's imagination
may even be expressing
itself in the way
he uses the soundtrack,
because it's
almost as if the
soundtrack may sometimes
be more interested in the
words or sounds coming
from the margins of
the frame rather than
from the center of the frame.
So there are these elements
of potential abstraction
that you always have
to contend with when
you're watching Altman's films.
The same thing
from another angle
could also be said to be true
in some degree of the way
the images work in the film.
Watch especially for the color
palette that Altman uses.
He plays around
with light and dark,
with a certain kind of
cold, dark, damp feeling.
And he contrasts that with
a kind of lighting that
suggests not incredibly
bright sunlight,
but a kind of nostalgic,
golden, sunset kind of imagery.
And if you watch the film, in
the very beginning of the film,
one of the things
that happens is
that sometimes this golden
sort of light appears indoors,
and the outdoors seem
gloomy and dank and dark.
And then later in the film,
this division between light
and dark undergoes
an alteration.
You might ask yourself why.
In one of the most
dramatic moments
toward the end of the film,
there is a group of murderers,
assassins ride into the town.
And they ride in accompanied
with the sun behind them,
accompanied by this
sort of golden haze
that Altman has
ironically associated
with comfort and pleasure
earlier in the film.
So both in terms of the
sound and the image,
we're engaged in
something new here.
In considering the
word "image," I
should also mention
Altman's montage,
Altman's habits of editing.
He's capable of the most
fluid and undistracted editing
if he wants to do it.
But he is actually
fonder of forms
of editing that are abrupt,
that are disconcerting,
that are mildly disorienting.
And that style is
part-- I don't mean
does this at all
moments of the film.
But that style, I think,
is part-- sometimes
he'll use abrupt cuts.
That style is part
of his art, I think,
but it's also part
of this desire
not to have things too smooth,
not to have things too neat.
His love of the
apparently imperfect
is part of what's
operating there.
Even a third element
of what I'm calling
his special or his
new realism might
have to do even with
the way he treats
not just the physical
spaces that you see,
but even the weather.
Watch how lousy the
weather is in his film
and how much damage
it does to people,
what an unpleasant thing
the weather actually is.
Snow really matters
in this film.
Bad weather really
matters in this film.
It affects the outcome of
the plot in certain ways,
as you'll see.
So this messy realism
I'm talking about even
extends to the way in which
the film treats the weather,
as you'll see as
the film proceeds.
The central features of the
traditional Western-- the hero
savior figure, the protagonist
figure, the gal from the East
who is often a schoolmarm who
falls in love with the hero,
and the idea that the
Western as a text,
as I've said many times
already, is always
a kind of founding story about
the equation of a community.
All of those
conventional structures
remain in McCabe and Mrs.
Miller, but they're reverted.
They're weird.
Let's take just a quick example.
The character played
by Warren Beatty,
he really is in some sense
the founder of the town.
There's a miserable
mining camp--
it just has a saloon in
it when the film opens.
And McCabe arrives.
He's the great gambler.
He's actually a visionary
entrepreneur in a certain way,
although in a very ironic sense.
The story is an ironic
entrepreneur's story,
a Horatio Alger story.
This gambler, McCabe,
comes to town,
looks the place over,
gambles for awhile
with these poor schlubs
who are suffering
on the very margins
of civilization
and then goes away.
When he comes back, he's
bringing prostitutes with him.
This town is not built
by noble intentions.
It's built by a whoremonger who
brings a bunch of prostitutes
into the town and
sets up the town's
first house of prostitution.
And in fact McCabe becomes
the biggest landowner
and the richest man in
town, not because he
has the entrepreneurial
vision of an Andrew Carnegie--
although actually, if we look
closely at Andrew Carnegie's
life, we might find
he more resembles
McCabe than his biographers
have acknowledged.
In other words, it's as
if what Altman is doing
is he's telling a kind of
ironic or mocking or antiheroic
Horatio Alger story.
And as the story unfolds,
certain lovely things
begin to happen.
One thing that
begins to happen is
we begin to see a soft or a
vulnerable side to the McCabe
character.
And when the schoolmarm
East figure arrives,
she's really from the East.
She's not even from the
East of the United States.
She has an English accent.
It's Julie Christie.
But she's not a schoolmarm.
She's a retired whore who
is now a manager of whores.
She's a whore mistress, an
expert in running whores.
And in fact, as soon as she
arrives in town and partners
with McCabe, McCabe really
begins to make money.
What we begin to
realize is McCabe really
doesn't know what he's doing.
McCabe had a kind of vision,
but he doesn't really--
and there's a wonderful scene
over a meal in which the Julie
Christie character who
wolfs down her food
like some John Wayne character,
while the McCabe character
looks very askance at her.
There's a scene in which
Julie Christie in effect
explains to McCabe
how little he knows
about how to manage women.
And then what develops is a kind
of love affair between McCabe
and this prostitute.
And what one begins to
realize is first of all,
the woman is much
smarter than the man.
And you can see her
despair being generated
as the story unfolds and McCabe
is manipulated by other people.
She knows the powerful
forces that McCabe will be up
against by the end of the film.
And she tries to discourage
him and help him,
but he's too caught
up in his macho
idea of what a man
is to allow himself
to see the wisdom of
what she's saying.
And he's actually sometimes
embarrassed by the fact
that she seems to know
more than he does.
Well, the relation between
McCabe and Mrs. Miller
inverts the normal love
affair relationship.
It shows us a woman who's
stronger and smarter,
although also much more cynical
and despairing than her man.
But McCabe's optimism and
sense of self-confidence,
which he loses pretty
quickly, is shown in the film
to be a function of his
ignorance and his innocence.
So the treatment
of the love story
and the treatment of the hero
savior figure in the film
is deeply humanizing
and deeply ironic.
They're actually more credible,
psychologically complex
characters, these two,
McCabe and Mrs. Miller,
than most of their predecessors
in earlier Westerns.
But they're also deeply
ironic embodiments
of their much nobler ancestors.
And the same thing
that I've just
been saying about the
hero and the heroine,
about the love story
and savior story
is also true of the
founding myth itself.
The name of this town
is Presbyterian Church.
Very good name, isn't it?
And it takes its
name from the steeple
of an unfinished church.
And I think the allusion to
unfinished churches in earlier
traditional Westerns is
certainly intentional.
It takes its name from the
unfinished church in the town.
And in fact as you will see,
the church is never finished.
You might watch how in
the plot that works out,
and why it works out,
and what role the church
and especially the minister who
is hanging out at the church
plays in the outcome
of the story.
Does the church, and
implicitly therefore does
religion play a constructive or
a destructive role in the film?
I'm not giving too
much away to tell you
it's obvious which
answer is appropriate.
It plays a destructive role.
Just as it's hostile to
certain political myths
about the founding
of the West, the film
is also hostile to our
pieties and complacencies
about the role of
religious institutions,
and especially in the
founding of our society.
So watch how it works itself out
and how that traditional icon
of the conventional
Western has its meanings
and its significance inverted
and subverted in this film.
There's one crucial film,
conventional Western,
to which this film
directly alludes,
I think, or at least
implicitly directly alludes.
It alludes to other
films as well,
but there's one especially.
And I want to show
you a clip from it,
because it has its
own distinction.
And it reminds you not
only about the sort
of ballad dimensions
of the Western,
but how stylized and
heroic in a certain way
the conventional Western is.
It'll be a nice contrast
with the antiheroic qualities
of McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
And this is a scene
from the very beginning
of a film made in the early
'50s called High Noon,
starring the first or second
most iconic of Western heroes.
If John Wayne was
the first, then
Gary Cooper was the second.
And this stars Gary Cooper.
But the main reason I want you
to see the opening of the film
is because it's very important
to McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
And there's no doubt that
Altman expects his audience
not only to be thinking about
many prior Westerns to contrast
with what happens
in this Western,
but he certainly
expects his audience
to remember specifically
the beginning
of High Noon and the way
High Noon plays itself out.
And perhaps also
certain other Westerns
play maybe almost as
significant a role in the film,
but High Noon especially.
And the main reason
that High Noon
is so important to
McCabe and Mrs. Miller
is that it's also a
drama that takes place
in the physical
spaces of the town.
High Noon begins brilliantly
with bad guys riding into town.
And we hardly see the hero
until the final images
of the sequence I'm
going to show you,
the Gary Cooper figure.
A man's been
released from prison
who's going to take vengeance
on the town marshal.
It's the day of the
town marshal's wedding
when the bad guys
are coming into town
to take their revenge.
The film itself, incidentally,
is a parable of the McCarthy
era of the early 1950s.
Like many Westerns--
and we've talked
about this-- like
many Westerns, it's
a disguised form of social
and political commentary
on the present.
And in this case, the
marshal's endangered.
A lot of bad guys
are coming after him.
He goes around the town asking
for help to set up a posse
to help him defend the town.
Nobody wants to help him.
He's left on his own,
and he has to fight
against these guys on his own.
And the drama of the
film has to do with this.
And as you'll see,
McCabe and Mrs. Miller
ends on a similar
note, in which McCabe
is up against a force of men
far larger than he, and also
professional killers.
And in that sense,
the end of McCabe,
the whole last
section of McCabe,
which involves McCabe defending
himself against assassins
who have been dispatched
by a corporation
that has tried to
buy McCabe out.
And when he's refused
to sell, they've
said, OK, we'll
take another route.
We'll eliminate him.
So Altman's telling
the story of capitalism
at its most aggressively
evil, instead
of the kind of fairy tales
that were told about how
the West was made by certain
mythological, optimistically
mythological Westerns.
So when McCabe defends
himself at the very end
against these larger forces,
one of the things that gives him
an advantage-- and one of
the most interesting passages
in the film occurs
here-- has to do
with his knowledge of the town.
He helped build the town.
So he knows every nook
and cranny of the town.
And he's able in part to hold
his own against four other men
who are actually much better
with violence than he is,
because of his
knowledge of the town.
Something of that
same kind of thing
happens at the end of High Noon.
The beginning of High Noon
is exciting because what
it shows is the film is
exploring the territory that it
will later return to.
So I'm showing it
to you because I
think in part it's interesting.
It's a nice contrast.
There's no question
that Altman expects
us to have this
film in our minds
when we're watching McCabe.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Do any of you
recognize this actor?
His name is Lee Van Cleef.
He played bad guys for
most of his career,
and then spaghetti
westerns came in.
He was reversed.
He began to play
less evil characters.
But he's an actor who's
associated with evil roles
in a series of Westerns.
The singer is Tex Ritter.
I also wanted you to
see this beginning
so you could hear this ballad
and contrast it with Leonard
Cohen's stoned aria.
Leonard Cohen sounds
like he's singing out
of the counterculture.
And watch the different
subject matter.
Only someone who had
never seen a movie
would fail to recognize
that these are bad guys.
Now how do you know
they're bad guys?
They're unshaven.
They have black hats.
There's a kind of
implicit symbolism
that the conventional
Western, even subtle ones
like this one, which
is a grownup Western,
it's an adult Western,
still make use of.
Altman will throw all
those kinds of markers out.
He thinks they're foolish.
Another church.
[CHURCH BELLS RINGING]
Think that's heavy-handed?
So you see how what's happening
here is a kind of visit
through the town?
It isn't until later
in the film that you
realize that every
space you go by
should have registered with
you, because the later action
of the film will take place on
these streets, in these barns,
on these balconies.
[INAUDIBLE]
Now, watch this shot.
And there's Gary Cooper,
who will be our hero.
And in fact, he's marrying
Grace Kelly, who in this film
is a Quaker.
And guess what one of the
climactic events in the film
is?
The Quaker lady fires a
gun to save her beloved,
violates her moral
principles and kills someone
to save her man.
OK.
[END PLAYBACK]
Now, I don't want you to think
that I'm suggesting that High
Noon is not a remarkable movie.
It is.
It's one of the very,
very good Westerns.
It has great subtlety
and power in its own way.
But I think that Altman
definitely wanted
us to think about the
radical differences,
between the universe
imagined in McCabe and Mrs.
Miller and the world as it's
imagined in even subtle, adult
'50s Westerns.
So many of these things
are crystallized for us
in the remarkable
conclusion of the film.
And I hope that you'll pay
a lot of attention to that.
It's an extended sequence.
And it operates according to a
principle of parallel action.
The church I mentioned
earlier catches fire.
Watch why it catches fire.
It's connected to the plot.
And while the church is
burning, most of the town
gets together in a kind
of comic bucket brigade
to put the fire out.
They are partly
aided by a new fire
engine, a mark of
the town's growth
that arrives at a certain point
in the history of the town.
The fire engine, I believe,
arrives at the same time
that Mrs. Miller
arrives in town.
They're both equally
important historical events
for the town's future.
But the arrival of
the engine suggests
the coming of civilization.
And there's a certain
sense in which
the fighting of the fire,
it's actually almost treated
like a slapstick event.
Real film buffs would actually
recognize visual allusions
or references to the
Keystone Kops era.
I don't want to exaggerate
this, but you'll see it.
I mean, there
actually is someone
carrying a bucket that has a
hole in it, water's falling,
that kind of thing.
And they're
incredibly ineffectual
in their trying to
put out the fire.
I don't think they
succeed very well.
The church essentially
is destroyed,
or at least the
steeple is destroyed.
But what happens nonetheless
is the town has come together.
And it's actually a moment
in which you actually
feel that the town's
identity is being forged
as these disparate
people-- the whores
and the barbers and
the respectable people
and the saloon keeper
all get together
to try to put the fire out.
So it is a moment in which
the town is really aborning.
While that is
happening, McCabe is
being stalked by the assassins.
The creator of the town,
the founder of the town,
is in a fight for his life while
this slapstick fire fighting
is going on.
Watch how that works itself out.
And then pay
special attention to
the profound, disturbing
ambiguities of the ending.
One of the reasons I admire
McCabe and Mrs. Miller so much
is that it seems in many ways
to satisfy the desire one
has for the trappings of
a conventional Western.
All of the elements
that you think
should belong to a serious
Western are present.
But they're present in such
ironized, such damaged, such
inverted form, that
they make you rethink
not only those particular
conventions, but the larger
mythological and
ideological work
that the Western mythology has
performed in American society
up to this time.
So it makes McCabe and
Mrs. Miller not just
a wonderfully entertaining film.
It's full of comic moments
and brilliant performances.
It is in its own
right a great work
of imaginative intelligence.
But it is an even larger
thing, it seems to me, because
of the intelligence
with which it engages
in this systematic
conversation with its aesthetic
and moral ancestry in the great
founding story of the Western,
which I suppose
must be identified
as America's most
distinctive and in some ways
most disturbingly revealing
story about itself.